Đại dễn thương trực Trung Quốc tại lây nụ quốc phó thông đã gửi thương đến tổng thức khi ăn trường như cửa trời restaurant,
nhằm làm só lập trường của bác kinh về phát biểu mời đây của thủ tụng Nhật Bản Tắc Kỷ Gí Sa Nè.
Trung Quốc cho sang phát biểu vì đây lo ăn của lãnh đạo nhật bản đã lần đủ tiêm gắn và đây này,
bởi quên từ vệ thực hệ, đồng thời đưa ra đến nhiều căn thì quân sự.
Điều mà bác tình đánh sáng là vượt dưới hạ và chức tiếp thấy thực lợi của lợi của mình.
Trong thư phía Trung Quốc hàng đệ phản đối mạnh mẽ, cho rằng phát biểu của Chú Kiều vì phạm nghiêm trọng lợt phát của tế,
bác kinh nhận mạnh sẽ bảo vệ chú quyền theo hiện chương liên của Nếu bị đe zua.
Trung Quốc cũng kêu gọi nhìn bản chấm rất càng đậu, bây kơi là kêu khách và giúp lại lợt phát biểu.
Chú kỷ đò nhấn người biểu tình tả nhìn bản cũng tổ chức tụng tập chứ phát phòng tụt ướng,
để yếu cầu bà là kỷ chi đưa ra lời ra thích, cũng như có lợi xin lỗi về phát biểu đáng kỷ ra nhiều sống só.